Last time we said that we can’t predict
exactly what will happen when we measure a
quantum system. But the Born rules tells us
how likely the possible out comes are.
In this video I’ll first teach you the easy
version of this rule that works for most simple
cases and will work for the all the stuff
we’ll do in the main quantum videos. Then
if you feel like it you can stick around for
the proper rule as well.
So as usual, we have our wavefunction in a
superposition of all the possibilities. If
I measure, it will collapse to just one of
these. To find the probability that it will
collapse to this state, all I have to do is
take that coefficient...and square it. That’s
all. If I had a superposition like this: then
the probability the cat is alive is half,
and dead is also half.
This version of the Born rule is very easy.
The actual rule is only slightly more complex,
in that it’s a little bit more involved,
but it isn’t hard at all. I’ll explain
that now if you’re interested- you won’t
need it for my main quantum videos, but you
will need it for any of the optional videos
I make on the maths of quantum mechanics.
So it’s up to you, skip to the next video
if you like.
Previously we looked at the case where these
coefficients are real numbers- the kind of
numbers we’re all used to using. But actually,
in quantum mechanics we are allowed to use
a more general type of number called complex
numbers.
I think the most useful way to think of complex
numbers for quantum mechanics is to see them
as arrows.
First, real numbers are kind of like arrows
too, pointing this or that way if they’re
negative. Their length is just the absolute
value of the number. Complex numbers generalise
real numbers, because they are arrows that
are allowed to point in any direction.
So the coefficients in the wavefunction are
like little arrows of different lengths. If
they’re all real, the arrows point left
or right. If they’re complex, then they
can point any direction. But the Born Rule
is the same in both cases: if you want the
probability of this state, look at the arrow
in front of it and find it’s length squared.
In real numbers, this is exactly the same
as squaring the number.
Let’s look at this example. If you have
this coefficient in front of this state, it’s
length is root 3 on 4, so it’s probability
is 3/4. But what if I rotated this arrow so
it’s not real anymore? The length is the
same, so the probability stays the same. You
might be wondering then, what’s the point
of using the complex numbers. It doesn’t
actually matter at all to the Born Rule, but
it really matters for what we’re looking
at in the next couple of videos, and so those
two states are actually very different physically.
So that’s the Born rule. But drawing little
arrows with the exact right length and angle
is really tedious, so I’ll incase you haven’t
seen it before, I’ll introduce you to the
more standard notation for complex numbers.
If we have an arrow like this, then we call
this direction the real direction, and that
direction the imaginary one. Then we want
to know how far we need to go in each way
to get to the end of an arrow. In this case
it’s d units in the real direction, e units
in the imaginary one, which you then write
as d+e i, where i represents one unit in the
imaginary direction. So instead of drawing
the arrow, we can just write down this. Here
are some other examples. This is really useful,
because now we can write wavefunctions more
compactly, for example:
And now it’s your favourite time of the
video! Homework time
By the way, I’ll type the questions up in
the description as well.
First a math one. If I have a complex number
a+bi, use pythagoros’ rule to find the length
of it. So what the probability of a state
with this coefficient?
Then of course, an interpretations question.
Many people have found the use of complex
numbers in the wavefunction very significant,
saying this shows that the wavefunction can’t
actually be real then. In other words, if
can’t be a real physical object. If so,
what kinds of interpretations of the wavefunction
would it rule out? But also, what do you think
of this conclusion, that something described
by complex numbers couldn’t actually represent
‘physical reality’? Are people taking
the word imaginary too literally?
This probably wasn’t the easiest video you
could have been watching on Youtube today,
so thanks for putting in the effort.